the White House has a message for anyone
who criticizes using American aid as
leverage
over a foreign nation get over it
there's going to be political influence
in foreign policy the White House chief
of staff offered no apologies for the
July phone call between President Trump
and the leader of Ukraine in which Trump
pressed for a Ukrainian investigation
into claims that a hacked computer
server that played a role in Russia's
2016 election meddling campaign had been
moved to Ukraine Trump was withholding
US military assistance to Ukraine when
he made the request that he also
mentioned to me and past the the the the
corruption related to the DNC server
absolutely no question about that but
that's it and that's why we held up the
money now there was a report demand for
an investigation into the Democrats was
part of the reason that he it was on to
withhold funding to Ukraine we look back
to what happened in 2016 certainly was
was part of the thing that he was
worried about in corruption with that
nation and that is absolutely a probe on
Trump's Justice Department has been
examining the origins of the Russia
investigation which the president calls
a hoax but in the July phone call with
Ukraine Trump also asks for an
investigation into his political rival
Joe Biden the White House claims that
part of the call had nothing to do with
withholding aid meanwhile Gordon Sunland
the US ambassador to the EU gave
closed-door testimony before Congress on
Thursday sunland was central in Trump's
efforts to pressure Ukraine to open the
investigations but said he was unaware
the president was after dirt on Biden in
his prepared remarks
sunlen testifies inviting a foreign
government to undertake investigations
for the purpose of influencing an
upcoming US election would be wrong
withholding foreign aid in order to
pressure a foreign government to take
such steps would be wrong I did not and
would not ever participate in such
undertakings still more witnesses are
scheduled to speak with congressional
investigators in the coming days as
Democrats charge forward with their
quest to peel back this onion of the
trumpet ministry
dealings with Ukraine the house will
likely vote on an impeachment before the
end of November with the Senate
preparing to put the president on trial
Heidi Joe Castro al Jazeera Washington